[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'europe cette semaine nous
allons nous pencher sur l'installation
de la technologie 5 g qui fait débat en
europe
dans la seconde partie de notre émission
partie des bas mais nous commençons tout
de suite par parler du sujet brûlant du
breakbeat le royaume uni a quitté
l'union européenne le 31 janvier dernier
mais continue d'appliquer les règles
européennes jusqu'au 31 décembre une
période de transition pendant laquelle
londres et bruxelles experts s'entendent
sur un accord commercial qui va régir
leurs futures relations
le gouvernement de boris johnson a
néanmoins souffle le chaud et le froid
et nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
maintenant en duplex de cork saimone
comme ni bonjour vous êtes le ministre
des affaires des étrangères d'irlande
vous avez été ministre bonjour depuis
2011 dans divers gouvernements pour le
fine gael le parti de centre-droit il
yad'ailleurs coalition au pouvoir entre
deux parti centriste fine gueule et fine
fé rôle et les verts aussi pour former
le gouvernement martin alors votre pays
c'est un pays membre de l'union
européenne il est très affecté par les
perspectives de brésil puisqu'il partage
l'île avec l'irlande du nord
selon vous où est-ce qu'on en est de ces
négociations
nous sommes clairement dans la dernière
ligne droite des négociations pour le
breakbeat
le royaume uni a officiellement quitté
l'union européenne
c'était au début de l'année au mois de
février nous arrivons à présent au terme
de la période de transition
cette période était censé donner le
temps au gouvernement et à l'équipe de
négociateurs pour négocier une nouvelle
relation avec un accord commercial pour
éviter les droits de douane et les
quotas qui sont un frein est inutile
pour le commerce et la relation
économique entre l'union européenne et
le royaume uni est en vérité il ya péril
en la demeure aujourd'hui
en effet si les deux équipes de
négociateurs ne parviennent pas à un
accord
si la fin octobre - le début du mois de
novembre
nous n'allons pas pouvoir convenir
mettre en oeuvre et à ratifier cette
nouvelle relation avant la fin de
l'année et si nous n'y parvenons pas au
début de l'année prochaine
la relation commerciale entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni sera très
différente
elle devra reposer sur les règles
commerciales de l'organisation mondiale
du commerce
ce qui implique des droits de douane
pour certains produits des quotas
certainement pour d'autres produits
ainsi que bien évidemment des
modifications des accords douaniers
l'obligation de faire des contrôles
sanitaires et phytosanitaires aux
frontières un besoin d'adaptation au
nouveau système de tva etc
à mon avis cela nuirait énormément à la
grande bretagne en particulier et à
l'irlande mais aussi à bien d'autres
pays de l'union européenne alors qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire dans l'arrivée
l'arceau l'un des grands points de
blocage c'est la pêche qui est très
importante puisque pour certains pays
comme l'irlande le vôtre donc la france
le mien les pays bas la belgique le
danemark qui pêchent dans les eaux
britanniques le négociateur européen sur
le breakbeat michel barnier a demandé
jeudi aux 27 de trouver un compromis
entre eux sur la pêche
la france ne sacrifiera pas les intérêts
de ces pêcheurs dans des négociations
globales du breakbeat dit l'elysée vous
comprenez oui il y a aujourd'hui deux
problèmes saillants deux obstacles qui
nous empêche pour le moment de parvenir
à un accord commercial
le premier c'est qu'il doit y avoir une
concurrence loyale entre les deux
économies l'économie britannique et le
marché unique européen et il doit y
avoir une compréhension claire
concernant les règles du jeu qui doivent
garantir cette concurrence loyale en
particulier concernant les subventions
publiques
il doit par ailleurs y avoir un modèle
de gouvernance pour gérer les différends
dans ce domaine modèle qui doit être
acceptée et reconnue par les deux
parties c'est le premier élément qui
pose encore problème et l'union
européenne a insisté pour qu'il y ait
des règles
je commune afin de protéger le marché
unique et s'assurer que le royaume uni
n'exporte pas vers le marché unique avec
un avantage concurrentiel car cela
serait évidemment inacceptable pour
l'union européenne
la seconde pierre d'achoppement tout
aussi problématique concerne la pêche
nombre d'entre nous qui avons travaillé
pour ce secteur j'ai été ministre de la
pêche en irlande savons à quel point la
pêche est un sujet sensible d'un point
de vue politique c'est lié à la
souveraineté à la protection de
l'environnement avec la bonne gestion
des restes des réserves halieutiques et
bien sûr le secteur de la pêche et des
communautés vivant sur le littoral vont
vouloir se faire entendre et agir
politiquement sur ce sujet
c'est pourquoi le mandat de michel
barnier concernant la pêche est très
difficile à accomplir
nous cherchons en définitive à protéger
le statu quo pour ce qui est de l'accès
aux eaux britanniques et de la part des
quotas de poisson dans les eaux
britanniques
je pense donc que la pêche risque d'être
le point le plus difficile peut être
réglées en vue de trouver un accord mais
n'oublions pas qu'en l'absence d'un
accord le problème de la pêche resterait
le même anneau dylan d'accord
provoquerait le chaos en mer pour les
bateaux britanniques et la flotte
européenne également le message
principal un communiqué et que c'est au
royaume uni d'être beaucoup plus
réalistes concernant ce qui est faisable
pour la pêche
si nous souhaitons trouver un accord il
faut dans l'égalité au monsieur ministre
des tensions sont apparues suite au
projet doit britannique qui remet en
question certains engagements qui
encadrent le breakbeat la corde divorce
il ya donc une nouvelle loi entérinée
par les députés qui revient sur les
dispositions pour la province
britannique d'irlande du nord
est ce que pour vous c'est une technique
de négociation de boris johnson tout
d'abord je pense que la proche du
gouvernement britannique three essai de
conclure à mettre un terme aux
négociations ne nous a vraiment pas aidé
je parle ici de la loi à laquelle vous
avez fait référence en définitive
le gouvernement britannique est en train
de dire c'est qu'il vote une loi pour
enfreindre le droit international
ils vont faire passer une loi nationale
qui est contraire et qui revient sur un
engagement pris dans le cadre d'un
traité international il y a moins de 12
mois de nombreux britanniques ont été
frappés par cette approche
d'ailleurs les cinq premiers ministres
qui ont précédé boris johnson se sont
exprimés publiquement pour dire que le
royaume uni ne devrait pas faire ça à
déclencher une procédure d'infraction
pour ce qu'elle considère comme une
violation du traité et pourrait saisir
la cour de justice européenne pour des
amendes vous contrer ce sur un retrait
du texte ça peut être effectif je pense
que l'union européenne n'a pas eu le
choix et a dû lancer cette procédure
juridique
si vous avez un traité entre lieux et le
royaume-uni d'à peine un an et le
royaume-uni vote des lois aujourd'hui
pour revenir sur certains éléments de ce
traité je pense que l'union européenne
n'a d'autre choix que d'emprunter la
voie juridique
ceci étant je pense qu à de nombreux
égards cette loi en particulier votée au
parlement britannique n'est qu'une
manoeuvre de diversion et je pense que
plutôt que de rentrer dans des
considérations juridiques qui découle de
la décision des britanniques
nous devrions plutôt nous concentrer sur
la résolution des problèmes actuels car
en agissant ainsi
cette loi nationale britannique devient
nulle et non avenue pour mieux
comprendre comment l'irlande du nord
province britannique est central dans la
négociation de l'accord de divorce et de
la future relation commerciale
je vous invite à partir tout de suite en
direction de cette frontière invisible
d'irlande du nord
notre reporter clovis casali s'y était
rendue avant le confinement on regarde
tous les jours joe parker traversent la
frontière nord irlandaise il n'a pas
vraiment le choix
[Musique]
ici on est sur mes terres côté irlande
du sud
ce matin il ya beaucoup de brouillard
mais quand vous regardez tout droit à
d'autres côtés de l'eau pouvoir les
autres terres de ma ferme en irlande du
nord
tous regrettent aujourd'hui de ne pas
avoir voté lors du référendum sur le
break site
sa vie va changer il envisage déjà de
vendre ses terres dans le sud en cas de
rétablissement d'une frontière physique
avec ses conséquences administratives
john sheridan vit lui aussi à la
frontière il a connu l'époque des
troubles dans la région avec des
décennies d'attentats de contrôle et
d'humiliation parfois c'était tendu avec
les douanes
ils nous arrêtent et et nous demandait
de vider notre camion on devait tous
sortir sur le bas côté de la route et là
il nous faisait attendre longtemps avant
de nous ordonner de tout remballer sans
nous aider c'était dingue
en traversant ce pont nous quittons la
république d'irlande pour l'irlande du
nord
la poste de sa majesté
la loterie nationale et les bureaux de
change
tous rappellent que nous sommes arrivés
au royaume uni
cet immeuble abritait les troupes
britanniques une base souvent visée par
des attaques meurtrières de
nationalistes irlandais les violences
entre les deux camps ont bouleversé la
vie locale dans les postes de douane et
les bases militaires ont été retirés
tout le monde a eu un sentiment de
liberté que certains n'avaient jamais
connu de leur vie lors du référendum
plus de 54% des nord irlandais avaient
voté pour rester dans l'union européenne
l'europe qui avait oeuvré aux accords de
paix en 1998 veut éviter le retour d'une
barrière physique mais aussi défendre
son projet politique et son marché
unique
effectivement l'irlande du nord 1
brigitte dur risque d'accroître le
risque de terrorisme viennent de mettre
en garde les législateurs britanniques
dans un rapport récent est ce que vous
le croyez vous en êtes profondément
convaincu ni vous avez vu dans ce
reportage qu'il s'agit là d'un problème
lié à l'histoire tragique de l'île
d'irlande les habitants d'irlande du
nord et de république d'irlande se
souviennent encore amèrement des
frontières entre le nord et le sud
c'est pourquoi nous avons tant travaillé
sur le breakbeat et avons bénéficié de
la solidarité de la france et de bien
d'autres pays de l'union pour trouver
une solution complexe afin d'éviter un
retour des frontières physiques entre le
sud et le nord de l'irlande et michel
barnier a fait un travail formidable
pour concevoir avec à l'aide de l'équipe
des négociateurs britannique
un protocole pour l'irlande du nord et
l'irlande qui fait aujourd'hui partie de
l'accord de divorce et est basée sur le
droit international
il fournit un dispositif qui permet de
garantir qu'il n'y aura pas de risque de
réapparition de frontières physiques
entre le nord et le sud non le type
théodard pour ce faire le royaume uni
est convenu de plusieurs obligations en
termes de contrôle de marchandises en
provenance de la grande-bretagne vers
l'irlande du nord pour s'assurer qu'il
n'y a pas de porte d'entrée non gardé
qui mène au marché unique européen en
passant par l'irlande du nord et par la
république d'irlande est un accord
relativement complexe mais qui est
aujourd'hui vu par les deux parties
comme une composante importante de la
corde divorce est donc ce qui est très
important d'un point de vue irlandais
ces deux non seulement parvenir à un
accord sur notre nouvelle relation
commerciale pour éviter de freiner
inutilement les échanges et d'attiser
les tensions au niveau politique mais
c'était également de voir la pleine mise
en oeuvre du protocole pour l'irlande du
nord et la république d'irlande dans le
cadre de l'accord de divorce
la question se pose maintenant avec
notamment la perspective d'un odile et
d'un à un accord de la réunification de
l'irlande le signe femmes c'est le parti
républicain présent dans les deux pays
qui a d'ailleurs bien fait des très bons
scores aux dernières élections appel à
un référendum sur la réunification
il suffirait d'une majorité à l'heure
actuelle votre gouvernement parle plutôt
d'une irlande
partager ça veut dire quoi de différent
tout d'abord je pense qu'il est
important de dire que dans le contexte
du breakbeat qu'il y ait un accord pour
la nouvelle relation ou non
il existe déjà un accord de divorce et
un protocole pour l'irlande du nord
ce protocole doit d'être mises en oeuvre
et fonctionner pleinement qu'il y à un
accord commercial ou non en ce qui
concerne la réunification de l'île
d'irlande
c'est une question qui devrait être
réglé sur le plan politique à l'avenir
l'accord du vendredi saint notre
processus de paix me permet à cette
discussion d'avoir lieu et si nécessaire
peut aboutir à une décision par un vote
démocratique au nord et au sud de l'île
d'irlande
mais ce n'est pas une question à régler
aujourd'hui car nous devons déjà réussir
à conclure les négociations sur le
breakbeat et gérer toutes ses
conséquences et je pense que lancer un
débat sensible et clivant sur la
réunification de l'irlande ne serait pas
une bonne idée
je suis nationaliste j'aimerais un jour
voir la réunification de l'île sur
laquelle je vis mais cela doit faire
partie d'un processus de garantie de
discussions de négociations
ce n'est pas un sujet qui peut être
traitée en coup de vent dans le cadre
des discussions sur le président
ce qui compliquerait à mon sens
l'obtention d'un accord c'est pourquoi
je cherche en priorité à régler la
question du breakbeat
le gouvernement irlandais a annoncé
lundi soir un durcissement de mesures de
prévention pour lutter contre la
pandémie et de kobe 19
sans aller jusqu'aux confinement que
vous recommandez pourtant les
conseillers médicaux
alors pourquoi une telle remontée des
cas et surtout pourquoi pas de
confinement
premièrement les restrictions mises en
oeuvre en irlande donc pour les
irlandais pour gérer la propagation du
coït 19 sont probablement les plus
strictes dans l'union européenne
nos chiffres sont d'ailleurs loin d'être
les plus mauvais dans l'union européenne
mais comme bien d'autres pays nous
assistons aujourd'hui à l'apparition
d'une deuxième vague et nous souhaitons
la contenir
c'est pourquoi nous avons imposé de
nouvelles restrictions ces derniers
jours nous nous entretenons avec nos
conseillers en santé publique
chaque jour mais nous devons aussi comme
d'autres pays tenir compte d'autres
composantes liées à la santé publique à
la santé mentale les pathologies la
gestion d'autres maladies à l' approche
de l'hiver 1
nous devons essayer également de gérer
les impacts économiques et financiers
des restrictions que nous devons imposer
et qui sont considérables et je pense
que nous voyons beaucoup plus de
solidarité et des prises de décisions
centralisée venant de bruxelles
par exemple dans le domaine des
déplacements à l'étranger dans l'accès
aux médicaments aux équipements de
protection individuelle et c'est donc
sur le plan collectif nous observons une
meilleure coordination au sein de
l'union européenne mais dans un même
temps nous voyons des pays qu'ils
prennent des décisions pour gérer la
situation en tenant compte de leurs
spécificités nationales merci monsieur
le ministre d'avoir été notre invité
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis vous
restez en notre compagnie je vais
rejoindre tout de suite au parlement
européen marie brémaud de public sénat
pour vous parler de ces petites choses
enfin plus exactement de leurs futures
technologies la 5g a tout de suite
[Musique]
bienvenue à bruxelles pour la partie des
bannis si l'europe
aujourd'hui on se penche sur vos petits
objets connectés du quotidien on parle
de l'installation de la 5g cette
nouvelle technologie de téléphonie
mobile 10 fois plus rapides que notre 4g
actuelle d'ailleurs bruxelles a exhorté
les gouvernements européens à accélérer
le déploiement de 7,5 g dans toute l'ue
eux censé booster la croissance est
indispensable pour nos besoins
d'interaction numérique en pleine
pandémie une pandémie qui nous sépare a
en attendant de nombreux élus et
citoyens ont exprimé leurs réticences
un peu partout en europe certains
s'inquiètent de l'impact sanitaire de
ces ondes électromagnétiques d'autre de
notre dépendance à la technologie
chinoise qui pose des questions de
sécurité nationale
pour en débattre nous recevons deux
eurodéputés aujourd'hui
dragos tu dois oracle rac et bonjour
vous êtes un jeune au président de la
commission spéciale qui vient d'être
créée justement sur la release
l'intelligence artificielle vous êtres
humains vous apparteniez au groupe
renew donc centriste la singer a
d'ailleurs démarré dans votre pays à
l'opérateur français orange chier à
appuyer sur des infrastructures
chinoises huawei et face à vous et bien
david cormand vous est également l'un
des membres de la commission spéciale
sur l'intelligence artificielle et en
même temps vous appartenez à celle sur
la protection des consommateurs et en
tant que chef de file des verts français
au parlement européen vous ne fait pas
mystère de votre défiance pour la 5g à
vous deux tout d'abord une première
question avantages et inconvénients de
la de la fange et monsieur toujours à
quai pour les avantages pensons clair
nous avons besoin des réseaux les ont
besoin d'un espace structuré c'est
solide
après avoir la puissance nécessaire la
capacité de bouger un peu les données de
gauche à droite pour tout ce qui est
connecté pour tout ce qui est là le
développement technologique du futur
donc le point de vue avantage besoin
je pense qu'on a besoin de 2,5 g mais
c'est pas n'importe quel sens que j'ai
donc je pense que la discussion le débat
c'est ici qu'elle dit de sang on va
développer sa david cormand avantages
inconvénients de s'engager pour démarrer
pas le problème que j'ai avec ce débat
sur la 5e rue c'est que j'ai du mal à
voir les avantages on nous dit on va
avoir besoin de transférer plus de
données oui mais pourquoi la 5g sera
indispensable
on a la fibre qui peut fonctionner aussi
sur la 4g elle est même pas déployé
aujourd'hui partout et on arrive quand
même à vivre et vous parliez c'est
intéressant pendant la crise du coc vide
de ce qu'avait été vraiment importante
pour notre subsistance et bien sûr les
connexions zoom qu'on a pu avoir été
importante mais moi ce que j'ai repéré
c'est pendant que cette période ce qui
était vraiment important c'est des
métiers qu'on avait oublié de voir comme
étant essentiels ceux qui remplissent
les rayons des supermarchés
les infirmières les éboueurs tous ces
travaux du quotidien je pense que c'est
ça qui était très important
pendant cette période les inconvénients
de la 5g pour moi et c'est le débat qui
m'intéresse
on va parler de la question sanitaire et
tout ça c'est au fond cette
infrastructure puisqu'il s'agit d'une
infrastructure au même titre qu'une
autoroute à une jeu à une ligne de
chemin de fer
cette infrastructure elle prépare quel
type de société
quel type de civilisation quel type de
consommation et ça c'est un débat qui de
mon point de vue doit être démocratique
aujourd'hui on nous dit la 5g sts à une
avancée technologique est un argument
d'autorité qui à dire du coup sans
discussion vous devez l'accepter
moi je pense que c'est avant tout une
question de civilisation donc un sujet
qui intéresse aussi nos citoyens
européens et commençons par cette cet
aspect c'est l'aspect sanitaire ce qu'on
nous dit attention il y aura des vous
allez être exposés à des fréquences plus
haute
alors vous vous dites quoi aucun aucune
étude ne prouve sa nocivité sur la santé
parce que vos concitoyens roumains ils
vont assez vite être confronté à 700 g
je pense que si on regarde l'impact de
n'importe quelle antenne a donc le 5 g
et le même chose que le 4g un peu plus
plus sont donc est ce qu'il ya un impact
sur la santé
meetic tout ça même chose que les lignes
de haute tension
l'électricité est ce qu'il ya un impact
santé sur sur les citoyens qui habitent
au retour de cette jambe j'ai pas vu des
études qui démontrent n'est pas concret
donc c'est normal justement qu'on n'a
finalement qu'on en installe sans savoir
c'est toute la question de la charge de
la preuve le principe de précaution
est-ce que c'est aux citoyens quelque
part de prouver la dangerosité pour
qu'on ne sache pas où est ce que c'est
ce qu'ils veulent les installer qui
devrait démontrer l'innocuité mais va
vous donner mais qui impacte
indépendante notamment la css a publié
des choses notamment en france où il dit
en gros on a fait preuve de dangerosité
1010 avant de la déployer
il faudrait d'autres études c'est ça qui
est intéressant
pourtant on va l'aider poignet quand
même avant donc en fait voyez ci
toujours ce qu'elle côté du principe de
précaution si tu es ce que c'est à
l'industriel de prouver l'innocuité de
ce qu'il veut développer comme
technologie ou comme produit ou est-ce
que c'est aux citoyens de prouver que
c'est dangereux en europe et en france
la tradition c'est plutôt la charge de
la preuve et à l'industriel aux
etats-unis par exemple
traditionnellement c'est plutôt
l'inversé
moi j'aurais aimé que justement ce
modèle européen soit retenu pour la que
je dirais même que la charge pour je
pense qu'on doit trouver une manière
d'avoir des études un peu dérouté
scientifique
parce que si on demande l'industriel de
convaincre bon ils sont subjectives sur
le sujet et c'est certainement ce n'est
pas les citoyens qui doivent qui doivent
prendre la preuve
donc pour moi vraiment on a besoin des
études scientifiques
outre ce n'est pas le cas c'est pas
c'est pas le cas pour l'instant
précisément un jeu vous propose quand
même d'écouter le président français
c'est votre président mais il est de
votre parti nous expliquer qu'il faut
vivre avec son temps
la france va prendre le tournant de la
5g parce que c'est le tournant de
l'innovation et j'entends beaucoup de
voix qui s'élèvent
pour nous expliquer qu'il faudrait
relever la complexité des problèmes
contemporains en revenant à la lampe à
huile
je ne crois pas au modèle amish et je ne
crois pas que le modèle amish permettent
de régler les défis de l'écologie
contemporaine david comment je vous vois
sourire vous orienter amish dans l'âme
dans les goussets c'était très
intéressant dans ce que vient de dire le
président de la république française
c'est que c'est révélateur de ce
qu'entendre les écologistes depuis des
décennies c'est vous voulez nous faire
retourner dans la caverne
vous voulez des vêtements aux peaux de
bêtes ce qui est pas bien d'ailleurs
pour la condition animale est ce qu'on
considère que par défi nation une
innovation technologique conduit au
progrès de l'humanité où est ce qu'on
pense que l'innovation technique n'est
pas forcément un progrès pour l'intérêt
collectif
c'est ça la question philosophique est
ce que je trouve dommage c'est que le
président de la république manque à mon
avis de vista de vision dans cette
affaire parce qu'il katic
ils capturent le propos est quelque part
c'est ce qu'on entend sur la 5g ses
arguments d'autorité
il ya un refus de rentrer dans le détail
du débat donc c'est assez méprisant pour
nous mais ça quelques paroles je me
remettrai mais c'est surtout mes prisons
pour la vision politique qu'on veut pour
l'avenir de l'europe et de la planète
alors qui me choque le plus dans ce tas
d'arguments d'autorité mais des
exercices pratiques
un test grandeur nature dans votre pays
la roumanie
monsieur tout d'aurac et trois villes
dont bucarest 2 millions et demi
d'habitants qui vont se voir installer
cette fameuse 5 g parmi les premiers en
europe du coup avec l'opérateur orange
qui était à la manoeuvre avec son appui
sur des infrastructures les plus
compétitifs c'est à dire des chinois de
huawei ça fait débat dans votre pays ça
va être ça fait des bases mais pas assez
j'aimerais bien qu'on a plus de débat
sur cela et je t en des premiers qui
acquit à qui a essayé d'avoir un débat
ce sera parce que de mon point de vue on
doit être très attentif aux comprenant
composantes techniques qu'on a deux dans
la technologie la boîte un peu noir de
technologie 5 g je pense que
particulièrement maintenant avec tout ce
qui s'est passé pendant la pandémie avec
le rôle de la chine etc
je pense qu'on doit être
plus attentive et j'aimerais bien que la
commission devient un peu plus réceptifs
sur ce sujet là j'ai l'impression qu'on
est c'était une business as usual qui
est pas du tout acceptable à et j'ai
demandé à la commission déjà deux fois
dont je regarde un peu ce sujet mais
c'est un enjeu de sécurité nationale
d'ailleurs les américains et certains
pays en europe ont décidé d'écarter le
chinois huawei non à la 5g peut-être
david cormand et encore moins avec les
chinois au motif de soupçons
d'espionnage
oui après vous avez raison parce que le
modèle économique et de la commission
spéciale que vous présidez à laquelle
participent fait faut qu'on montre que
le business model du capitalisme du 21e
siècle c'est collecter de la donner
nourrir l'intelligence artificielle pour
en faire et pour faire de nous des
consommateurs encore plus et des
consommatrices encore plus accros et
donc à la question de l'impact
économique de géants étrangers on parle
des chinois m'enfin pourrait parler
aussi des gars femmes cambridge
analytica qui a eu un impact y compris
sur les choix démocratiques dans des
pays occidentaux
c'était via facebook donc via les gars
femmes américains n'ont pas tomber dans
le truc
oui il faut faire attention à wise enfin
les gars femmes c'est pas terrible non
plus et surtout savent créer des géants
économiques qui vont avoir une emprise
sur l'économie de demain sans que nous
puissions même défendre un autre projet
c'est quoi le modèle économique des gars
femmes c'est au fond à commerce cents
commerçants c'est amazon c'est
l'automatisation des ports ça aussi
c'est que donc des transports c'est
l'autonomie des camions autonome donc
plus de joker plus de contrainte
nécessaire un débat un petit peu
différent comme kiss nous c'est un débat
véritablement sur les possibilités
qu'elle offre d'espionnage de tourisme
etc
de la part d'un d'un géant chinois est
véritablement la question aussi se pose
parce qu'il est le plus compétitif et
peut-être même un peu plus avancés on a
quelques champions européens un nokia
qui peut peut-être se hisser à son
niveau on a ce que vous dites il faut
que la
a commission soit les risques il faut
qu'elle soit claire au point d'exclure
les chinois et de favoriser les
européens je pense que la commission
doit être clair sur les sur les méthodes
que les gouvernements mais aussi la
commission doivent employer pour
s'assurer qu'il y a la composante
sécurité qui est très bien les mêmes
espionnage qui était bien monitoring et
de dans la technologie 100g de ce que je
veux maintenant on a déjà quelques états
membres et c'est pas seulement la
roumanie c'est la portugal c'est vrai
quelques états membres qui ont déjà
organisé leurs marchés publics qui ont
déjà déployé d une partie de la
technologie
donc ma première question la commission
et qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les états
membres qui sont déjà avancés dans
l'implantation de 5 g avec de la
technologie chinois comment on va
remplacer cette composante si on veut
les remplacer et deuxième question si on
a des champions européenne vous a dit
nokia élections les immenses et sais pas
comment on peut les aider pour qu'ils
peuvent de manière efficace et bien sûr
faisable de point de vue économique
qu'ils peuvent bien sûr à l'emploi c'est
ne pas interdire carrément david cormand
de quoi le servir dire interdire les
chinois c'est à dire on est en train de
parler de sujets différence c'est ce
qu'on appelle les tuyaux à l'époque de
la fibre là c'est pas les tuyaux c'est
les en tête qui détient les antennes
c'est un débat mais au delà de qui
détient les antennes qui les fabrique
qui les installent vient à quoi elles
servent
qu'est-ce qu'elle transforme comme blé
ces deux sujets dame pose problème même
si vous avez ça sera mieux des antennes
european aux européennes avec un géant
européen qui installe les antennes 5 g
quel modèle économique ça favorise qui
va les utiliser
et donc là on retombe sur ce que je vous
commencez à vous dire sur l'histoire des
gars femmes
donc moi si vous voulez on peut se faire
plaisir et dire on interdit les chinois
car un truc de patriotisme leur permet
c'est un aspect de la question pour moi
la question fondamentale c'est à quel
type de société
on arrive à la mi septembre les pays
l'union européenne avait assigné en
moyenne que 27 5% des fréquences selon
la commission
l'europe est à la traîne en matière de
5g pourquoi bon je pense que du point de
vue calendrier et préparation je pense
que
un décalage qui viennent de ça je pense
que la question sécurité la question est
ce qu'on laisse des acteurs chinois par
exemple participé à cette technologie
c'est une question qui est venue tard
dans le débat dans les discussions et ça
a introduit en période de donner de
point de vue on doit encore débattre ce
n'est pas parce que je veux on est en
retard même de plus mais parce que je
pense que c'est une question
existentielle politique c'est un débat
qu on doit avoir
est-ce qu'on veut que les données qui
vont passer sur ses 5 j'ai une question
très important des données personnelles
mais même des données gagnantes
exactement ni dormir big data passe par
des tuyaux par des antennes à qui on ne
contrôle pas et c'est pas seulement
question de patriotisme ici c'est une
question de prendre vital de santé
économique de sécurité économique et de
sécurité stratégique aussi le grand
argument de la commission européenne
c'est que ce boum boum numérique il doit
participer à un plan de relance massif
de l'union européenne qui passe
forcément par ce secteur d'autant et
c'est vrai qu'il ya un point point de
fût fort pendant la pandémie
on a vu à quel point ce support été
utiles à votre démocratie quand vous
avez dû voter vous ne pouviez pas venir
au parlement européen ou encore à
l'enseignement à distance des élèves
l'expérience montre que tous les
exemples que vous donnez ils ont été
possibles sans la sangle j'ai un peu
saturé quand même un tout et encore des
zones blanches en europe 1 oui d'accord
mais ça c'est palace alger qu'il résout
il en faut encore plus d'antennes 5g en
en nombre d'installations que les
technologies actuelles donc tout ce que
vous évoquez
ça a été possible sans la sag les
premières remarques après moi je suis
sceptique quand on parle de relance et
c'est tout le débat qu'on a ici ailleurs
quel type de relance on veut et ce qu'on
pense que il faut reprendre repartir sur
les bases qui étaient les nôtres avant
ou est-ce qu'il faut changer de modèle
moi je dis je défend plutôt un nouveau
modèle plutôt un modèle qui est moins
consommateur énergétique
or la technologie les infrastructures
que va générer les flux que vont générer
dont on dit qu'il va augmenter avec la
monnaie
alternatif qui est celui qu'il faut
mettre en place un modèle plus sobre
avec des objets qui durent plus
longtemps
on lutte contre l'obsolescence
programmée on favorise plutôt la
réparabilité plutôt que de renouveler
constamment des objets connectés au net
c'est un modèle qui est plus l'on
applaudit vous vous défendez un autre
modèle mais tout notre internet
aujourd'hui un dépens des américains
tout ne téléphonie va dépendre des
chinois ce qui n'a pas déjà perdu la
bataille d'un géant européen
en quelques mots je pense que non mais
je pense que le moment est maintenant on
n'a pas à faire de plus c'est maintenant
ou jamais je pense qu'on peut encore
être relevant dans les débats dans la
grande compétition le global mais on
doit agir maintenant
c'est pour ça que dans la nouvelle
commission spéciale qu'on a on veut
donner un peu de coups un petit coup
politique pour pour inspirer un peu la
commission à être un peu plus ambitieux
et aussi avec les états membres de
donner une nouvelle vision pour pour la
décade végétal qui qui commence
maintenant
un géant d'accord mais un jeu européen
et vert c'est ça oui c'est autant que
possible l'idéal c'est sur ces questions
sur cette console moi je pense qu'il
faut que l'europe ne cherche pas à
singer a imité les modèles qui a
forcément les modèles qui ailleurs je
pense que aussi faire attention de ne
pas créer un cheval de troie qui
permettra justement à des géants par les
dégâts femmes de pouvoir encore plus
infiltrées notre économie européenne
c'est ce débat global qu'il faudrait
avoir là quelque part on se pose pas à
mon avis l'ensemble des questions qu'il
faudra se poser pour les stratégies des
temps à venir merci à vous en tout cas
d'avoir soulevé toutes les questions sur
ce sujet et ce seront bien aller mot de
la fin merci à nos invités d'être venu
sur le plateau merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis vous restez sur nos
antennes à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]